what I love about gaming is that at
least the kinds of games we make they're
really interactive storytelling
my name is Omar Sadiki I'm the CEO and
co-founder of Kiwi our titles are
immersive character oriented you know
over the course of the last two years
we've had five that have been in the top
25 grossing the kinds of games we make
and require a few things to be
successful one they need to be able to
be distributed really broadly - they
need the ability for us to really have
analytics infrastructure or third they
really need robust in-app transactions
and that whole monetization
infrastructure two years ago when I was
going around and saying like you know
we're gonna starting a new gaming
company and we're gonna be focused on
making games only for Android I think
everyone looked at me and was like why
and two years later everyone looks at me
and says that was a very smart thing to
do what's interesting about the
ecosystem as Android becomes so
prevalent is is that it's becoming more
and more of a social experience you play
games you talk to your friends about
them you always have them on you and
with the platform itself you can
actually integrate an interface with
people check leaderboards to see how
your friends are doing and making it a
comparative social experience
every six months the revenue we've been
generating has been doubling it's great
to be a part of that type of growth as
well some of the key features of Android
that has really helped us are like being
able to push out apks and content
immediately to our users doing partial
deployment to a segment of users and
test it out and then roll it out to the
remaining ones and also the
international penetration has been
really helpful to be able to reach a
larger audience when we design games we
don't just focus on necessarily creating
an immersive experience we recognize it
where's going to be playing these games
on the train in boring meetings where
wherever and we want a design experience
is specifically relevant for how they're
actually interacting with it at this
point we've had games that have been on
Google Play for almost two years now and
they still have a large community of
players who play every single day and
that's our challenge is to keep it fresh
and to keep it interesting